the Marvel Cinematic Universe isn't done
with the Avengers but that doesn't mean
that fans should expect more of the same
speaking with MTV News at San Diego
comic-con 2019 studio bus Kevin Feige
revealed that mighty Marvel indeed has
plans for its flagship superhero team
moving forward but that said team will
look quite a bit different from what
we're used to this shouldn't come as too
big of a shock because in terms of brand
recognition the Avengers name is without
equal in the world of mainstream film
each of the four films that have been
released so far with that word in the
title have grossed over a billion
dollars at the worldwide box office the
Infinity saga culminating Avengers
endgame even became the all-time
box-office champion surpassing the
decade old record previously held by
James Cameron's Avatar
[Music]
according to Feige a new iteration of
the Avengers is on the horizon but it's
not likely to feature many if any
revamped versions of heroes were
familiar with the King geek was asked
point-blank by mtv news if he and the
rest of the Marvel Studios braintrust
know what the next Avengers team will
look like and he replied yes after a
lengthy pause Feige continued it will be
a very different team than what we've
seen before
that's what endgame was all about it
will be a very different incarnation of
the team with some people you've already
met and some people you haven't met yet
whatever form this team eventually takes
it seems safe to say that we won't see
another proper Avengers film for quite
some time considering that the entirety
of Marvel's phase 4 slate was announced
during the studio's rapturously received
comic-con panel and there was nary a
giant team-up flick to be found there
may be a few clues however hidden in the
details we know so far
about phase 4 and beyond first it's been
revealed that two prominent characters
will be getting their introductions by
way of standalone solo flicks in the
coming years one during phase four and
one during phase 5 February 12 2021 will
see the release of shang-chi and The
Legend of the ten rings which will
introduce audiences worldwide to the
legendary master of Kung Fu along with
drum roll please
the actual Mandarin you want something
take it
although the guns are all fake I
wouldn't trust me with the real ones
what we said the actual Mandarin get out
of here Trevor anyway Marvel hopes that
the flick with it's mostly Asian cast
and behind the camera talent will be the
kind of paradigm-shifting event that
2018 s black panther proved to be and if
this works out like we all know it
probably will the character would be a
fine inclusion and team-up films in the
future in the comics shang-chi although
he has no superpowers for most of his
heroic career is among the finest
unarmed combatants in existence more
than capable of going toe-to-toe with
super-powered opponents phase 5 will
bring us the solo vehicle for that
deadly smack-talking half-human
half-vampire blade who was portrayed by
Wesley Snipes in the successful film
trilogy of the
late 90s and early 2000s in the MCU the
daywalker will be played by two-time
Oscar winner Maher Sheila Ali and it
seems unlikely that Marvel would cast an
actor of that caliber without having
some pretty big plans for the future
save for those two additions to some
potential super squad well who knows
Feige suggested to MTV News that though
there may never be another culmination
of a decade-long arc like endgame that
doesn't mean that the future of the MCU
won't play host to some thrilling events
he elaborated that's what I love about
the Marvel comic method of storytelling
I love things that build up they build
to a crescendo they all get together
they separate the change and now that we
get to do that not just in movies but on
these mega events series on Disney Plus
it's just invigorated all of us at
Marvel Studios to keep going Feige and
companies certainly haven't steered us
wrong so far and like you we can't wait
to see what they have in store for us in
the years ahead it'll be interesting to
see whether Marvel can make household
names out of some relatively lesser
known characters yet again which is
almost certainly the plan and we
wouldn't bet against them check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop or videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]